de multiplions toutes les occasions
possibles ici au Sénat comme hier avec
le commerce extérieur ou la ferme France
pour vous alerter sur le déclin
économique de la France par le poids des
charges et des normes vous nous répondez
que les éleveurs français doivent monter
en gamme pour trouver des marchés avec
des marges plus élevées selon les
objectifs de la stratégie farm to fork
ou Green Deal bilan dans la filière
agricole la ferme France a perdu la
bataille face aux importations pour la
restauration collective ou les plats
préparés alors il nous reste le poulet
du dimanche le labellisé si vous ne
défendez pas c'est la belle qui ne sont
chers tant pour les producteurs que pour
les consommateurs nous perdrons cette
ultime bataille nous constatons tous les
jours que les normes et les
surtranspositions s'appliquent aux
agriculteurs français et que notre
administration se développe toujours
plus pour contrôler nos productions
plutôt que des produits qui sont
importés résultat nos fermes ne sont
plus reprises par les jeunes vous vous
étiez engagé à faire respecter les
clauses miroir nous attendons des suites
vous acceptez au contraire une nouvelle
concurrence déloyale à nos productions
et probablement emplois ruraux affiliés
et labels monsieur le ministre la ferme
France brûle mais nous regardons
ailleurs
[Applaudissements]